the Joe Rogan experience imagine that's
your daughter your daughter goes and
joins Isis like the obvious thing about
this the the Manson murders why I'm so
until I have no idea I got problems but
the Manson murders those girls were like
17 and 19 imagine when you're 17 but
they were also homeless so you're
dealing with people that are probably
crazy crazy LEDs that was their family
right this was like the first time they
had ever had like real family and they
didn't know the murder what the exactly
they were gonna do til they got to the
house then they're like alright I guess
one girl dips out the other two are like
alright let's do this it was once upon a
time in Hollywood their depiction of it
whisk you saw it loved it I cannot get
enough of the 60s I want to 68 portrayed
in that movie like amazing yeah I mean
Brad Pitt was great in that movie
Leonardo DiCaprio she went at Oscar
they were both amazing how about the way
they depicted Bruce Lee that was [ __ ]
up was it was it was it not I don't know
like I and I'm sure Bruce Lee's dodging
and jump all over us with the stuff I
Bruce Lee was a philosopher it was he a
fighter was he really that much of a
badass
I don't know like I've heard I've heard
he is I've heard from people like no
he's never been really a lot of fights
I've heard I've heard both so what I
thought was great is they put like
Quentin Tarantino put his perspective on
it where it's like I've heard that
narrative and I loved it because I've
what I've seen it both way heard where
he wasn't that much of a badass like he
doesn't have a crazy record yeah but it
wasn't just that it was he was a dummy
in the movie and the problem was in real
life there's no evidence that he was
ever at like an egomaniac dummy who was
very interesting guy and very insightful
and I do and I believed it he was like a
philosopher and he's brilliant
but when it comes to the actual
toughness we don't we don't know but we
don't we don't know for sure but that
that's one yeah you've heard that
narrative before right what narrow that
like like he's not an actual tough guy
well what I had heard was that it at the
time he was incredibly innovative in
terms of martial arts but he didn't
really fight and he had like a sparring
match wants it a tournament yeah and he
had some street fights but he didn't you
know he wasn't like John Jones and
but then I've also heard that it was
this badass and fought other dudes from
dojos and he's amazing I'm somewhere in
the middle I bet he's a big soval so
what was not the problem though the
problems they made him look like a
buffoon there's no evidence it's a movie
everyone's crying about it's going to be
about a real person who was a real
legacy in a box come on Joe
it's a [ __ ] Quentin Tarantino movie
and the wit that they don't give it
spoil the ending with the ending -
that's not real
well that's true then they had a totally
different ending like you're living to
make believe everything no no one's real
in that except for like obviously the
the ranch is real where they went
Charles Manson who's barely in it the
Manson Family yeah but everyone
everyone's kind of dumb like even even
Leonardo DiCaprio his characters a bit
of a kid he's a bit of a dumbass yeah
but that real guy might have been a
dumbass I mean we don't know but we do
know that about Bruce Lee either yeah
but there's a lot of evidence that Bruce
Lee was this brilliant insightful guy
and in that movie they made him a
caricature of that and you have a
problem with that I did I stood up I
didn't laugh laugh I don't have a
problem with it because it was so good
cuz I thought I thought Bruce Lee's
gonna beat the [ __ ] out of Brad Pitt and
then when you see that when I went that
twist is hilarious I don't expect it and
I think of Bruce Lee is a badass which
he is whether he's been in a million
fights or not - wait what he's done for
martial arts is is not present it's
amazing what he did so take that twist
for me in the MOOC that's what I want
from the family's reaction oh my god the
sisters serving his daughters pissed
there's you beep if that's my dad yeah
like [ __ ] you and that movie so big it's
like [ __ ] you guys
because once last time Bruce Lee got
brought up besides Jesse at roots a
fight selling a Bruce Lee t-shirt once I
think got brought the [ __ ] up the dude
who played Bruce Lee was not going
trended enough yeah sure been more
shredded yeah I just know Trevor
see I like the twist because a it's not
real be you thought Bruce oozing beat
the [ __ ] out of bad man I did for sure I
was like oh he's about to get [ __ ] up
a new brand also the way he Bruce Lee
doing that jumping flying kick his
signature kick that's probably how a
totally talking about but the guy who's
been in fights I get that [ __ ] a day
Bruce Lee's philosophy in real fights
though was that keeping things simple
like leg kicks and quick punches you're
living reality joke you're living in the
legacy of Bruce Lee which is probably
true but in a Quentin Tarantino movie
that was [ __ ] great man I thought
that movies brilliant movie was
brilliant I did not like the Bruce Lee
things because I thought it was it
wasn't necessary was there they made him
look like a dork but everyone sucked his
dick so to mix it up it's fantastic
like Bruce Lee everyone you know he's
the best and I agree he's the best so
it's a movie that's supposed to be about
a real guy
that has a real legacy and they made him
look like a buffoon it's the man beast
though I know but they you know you're
making the guy look like a [ __ ] idiot
yeah but anyone wasn't really in it it
wasn't it at all not at all he's a
brilliant philosopher and wouldn't it
for martial arts is that is amazing but
in the movies great
that's what's great cuz we know he's
great and you assume he's gonna beat up
Brad Pitt you're a weird [ __ ] guy I
don't know why you like they think
that's good yeah I like the twist like
if you woulda beat Brad Pitt up I went
all right well yeah moving on I didn't
think that was gonna happen I thought
Brad Pitt was gonna [ __ ] him up I'll
hide in it Brad Pitt knew how to fight
yeah who's a bigger guy and he knew how
to fight and the reality is a bigger guy
who knows how to fight who really knows
how to fight is gonna [ __ ] up 130 pounds
I know you're thinking about it too much
do you think about things talk about
weight you want to do though yeah you do